my use at all if your man commented on
your body in the bedroom whether you be
offended I wouldn't
oh no I mean I wouldn't like I just do
something about it it depends on what
they say though and how this is and I
think it's also the heart behind it as
well well no yours as as well as the
heart oh sorry okay
um as well as the heart because I trust
my husband say anything that he says I
know it's not like malicious but also
my husband is a bit of an enemy of my
progress because I want to lose weight
and he's very like oh but you look
amazing but sometimes I just feel like
if your partner says oh yeah I'd love if
you like toned up it gives you that
extra motivation to go tone up do you
know I think there's a there's a way of
going around it so it's not like you
have to trust the person when you was
when we was doing this and I felt this
yeah there's there's ways around it yeah
my mama just say you're fat you've got a
buddy do think about it
I agree with you because if they say
you're getting busy with your guy and
then you're saying oh you're a bit heavy
today excuse me why are you saying it
like that well how do my headliness and
get stronger then it's just the way that
is not funny imagine
no I was just saying like if let's say
you're in the moment you know your
mind's in a different universe and all
of a sudden you hear silly coming like
you're a bit heavy today
we just had dinner
I mean is it true I mean
like if he says it is it true
like what does it matter how he says
it's true it's true he's not saying
you're ugly you know I understood it in
the moment I don't think that matters if
it's true I think why are you saying it
in the moment
in the position yes yes I agree with
that I said I think it's important that
you date guys that like your body type
your body type can change thank God yeah
um
a couple of babies ago
I mean you've grown together as a couple
though yeah so by what she said like he
met me one day he could be like oh but I
want you to go back and go back to that
but you could lose weight you could he
doesn't care but I'm saying if he cared
I probably would be more motivated yeah
that's what I mean it wouldn't just be
like my internal I want to lose weight
but he's like you know can you buy me a
chocolate then he'll buy me like a Duo
but that's just helpful that's just you
there are a lot of men who still expect
their women to even if she doesn't look
exactly like how they met before kids
they still expect their women to look
somewhat the same so
luckily or your man's like you know we
can eat chocolate together or whatever
but there are a lot of men that are like
yeah she's just you know and there are a
lot of women that feel offended by it
because it's like oh I've pushed out
this baby but like well I just think
sometimes men feel like they can't say
things that are true to us and like we
want them to communicate it in a
feminine way yeah and it and they're not
women so when you say like it's how you
say it it's very confusing to guys
because they're like well it's true
yeah men are required to
be gentle with women because we are not
like them so I think in the same way we
should not expect men to deliver in a
way that a female would they need to
recognize that they're not speaking to a
male so yes I feel like men should be
able to be truthful but they should do
it gently because they speak into
someone chanting yeah I I just think
that women need to grow our backbone and
stop making excuses because if you're
fat you're fat if you've got to put on
what you've got to put on wait mama told
me I was four pound overweight I lost
four pounds he's just the same thing on
what she said
you're putting a bit of weight in you a
bit heavy and I was like yeah you're
right
is that it all depends on your
relationship and how you talk to each
other because word is quite
straightforward and blunt to the point
where people like oh my god did he
really say that I'm like yeah and it's
true and I'll tell you yes look at you
begin you know to your comment it was
like uh because you said but did you
feel like that so let's say the woman
disagreed and then he's like okay but I
want you to you know like get fit and
she's like no I don't really feel like I
can't use you if you then stepped out
are you saying that's like wrong or like
his eyes are not gonna wander I mean yes
sit down and work it out like they they
what he has he's like he's telling you
like babe please go to the gym ask
something and I and I said no I don't
feel like it your resolve can't be then
I'm just gonna step out on if like if
there's a resolve that goes beyond us
continuing this conversation until we're
both like not satisfied but there is
some kind of Middle Ground here what was
the middle ground believe me well again
I think that's a lot of guys feel
trapped in marriages because they don't
want their kid they don't want to put
their kid at every statistical
disadvantage they possibly could yeah so
it's like if they step this is just how
they see it it's like if they step out
and you never find out because they're
you're not doing the things that they
ask them to do they a lot of times guys
feel like it's Justified no I know I
know someone that said because he has a
child he will never leave the he's
child's mom
um but if he's unhappy he will go about
his business behind her back but he will
never leave her and I said to him leave
her he said never because my son's there
and I don't want him not not because he
fears that she would keep him away from
him it's because he doesn't want his son
to grow up outside of mom and dad lives
here but together they're happy the son
sees happy Parents I don't know because
if they did I think good on him yeah
yeah
what for cheating and staying yeah yeah
okay
there should be some kind of mutual
agreement between the two parents if
that's the case if they're not happy
but not him he said him but what she
don't know don't hurt her in it oh no no
you don't think so no because she can
get infected by what she doesn't know
might hurt that's something yeah if he
cares so much about his child he's going
to care so much about his worst vagina
you don't know that because he cares
about his child yeah he's staying that's
his standard he's staying because of his
child he could leave so because his
standards are so high he's not gonna go
out and cheat
and get something for he's going to be
extremely careful because he's careful
anyway that's why he's staying there
I didn't agree
do you guys believe a man can love you
but still cheat yes yeah
I do yeah I really do like long-term
cheating or do you like oh I've slept
with this person and I I've realized I
was wrong I think sometimes they just
fall into some stripper you know yeah
and he he reckons all men cheat in a
certain type of way he said my friend
he's my read he calls it like a transfer
window like a window he said I have my
windows I do what I do and then you know
what I go back I'm a good dad I'm a good
husband but that's it but when that
window opens it's open and when it's
shut it's shut I don't think it will men
cheat neither do I I'm so sorry yeah I
refuse to say mama don't cheat I just I
do think they can sleep with someone
else else and still love you
mathematics I think so but not like a
long-term relationship with a whole
other family yeah exactly a double life
I don't know I really think guys can
love two women at the same time yeah I
really like I mean they did it
throughout all of his history you're
gonna you're gonna tell me that all
throughout all of history when it's 17
it's one man reproduced for every 17
women that none of them loved their
wives
isn't it as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible